well some people may not know there's a
spot in downtown las vegas it's known as
abbey road and it's really
a nod to the beatles famous uh album
cover
and it was the site of a small but a
really impactful tribute to lennon
tonight
eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough on fremont street for the
ceremony
fremont street turns into a shrine for
john lennon and the beatles for the 40th
anniversary of john lennon's passing who
could have imagined
all the people remembering john lennon's
legacy
40 years after his passing well that's
what took place here on fremont street
tonight
as several people came out to speak and
sing in honor of the musician
and peace activist the event started at
six o'clock and was led by organizer
paul casey
who said a few words and then had fellow
supporters come up and sing
songs one of which was the beatles song
imagine
[Applause]
the beatles were they changed everything
changed rock and roll
they changed how we live how we think
about things and the things that they
said
were applicable then and today and it
will for the next 50 years and so i
think it's their message of love
peace hope imagine the future and be
positive
casey created abbey road crossing las
vegas in 2014
on fremont street a showcase of this
beautifully painted road to commemorate
the beatles album that came out
in 1969. the location's perfect this is
almost an identical
size street and the crosswalk as you
would find in westminster
london england this is exactly the the
difference is that
ours are painted complete white our
little ladder
and each of the stripes represent
the beatles sergeant pepper album the
green representing john lennon
the pink representing ringo starr the
blue for paul mccartney and the red for
george harrison the
event tonight lasted for about an hour
with artwork and instruments displayed
along with an actual suit john lennon
wore
reporting from fremont street madison
kimbrough 8 news now